hey what's up welcome back to our
channel my name's samuel and i'm amanda
and this
is the samuel and amanda show where we
talk about money
marriage and life so what you've been up
to this week
this week's been fun i've been
furnishing and dressing some houses
as you know so it's been quite busy and
different for me quite exciting
i've even had your input on some of your
market research right yeah samuel did
some market research and he suggested
some colors that i was like
i'm not sure but actually i think it
turned out quite nice
and our credit where it came from the
market research actually came from jl
spooner okay
she rented out she said that she had
three rooms one of them had this
particular green paint
and she said that room everybody wanted
and she could have rented it like 10
times over
i thought um so you know
we kind of like played around into
market research have to shout out to jr
spooner we use the paint and it's been a
treat yeah
really well it's really good rented the
rooms out over and over so um so you've
been what like frantically
where where are you where do you order
stuff from oh my goodness just here
there and everywhere
um do you use your like interior design
um what was it
your certificate that you got your
certificate my interior design
certificate i mean i used some of those
skills
which is quite cool uh so that was
really good and then also i got to meet
finally
a lot of your students that i see on
your zoom calls so yeah
five in person yeah at the crash courses
that was really really fun
i meant lots and lots of girls lots of
ladies in property which is really
really cool
like patricia kilty yes like amelia
like um oh annalise
yeah alexandra there's loads of
graziella
18 months you've been seeing them yeah
you've seen them on the screen
yeah yeah great well i've been um
running the courses eating meat and
vegetables still so now is the
i've got two more days of meat and
vegetables and fruit only and then it
would have been a full month with zero
carbs which has been amazing
um and i've been working on some top
secret stuff
which i cannot talk about otherwise i'd
have to remove the video
[Applause]
but come in real soon if you watch the
if you watch the uh winners wednesday
coming this week
you will know it's gonna be just insane
all i'll say is you have no idea but you
need to subscribe to this channel and
watch what's coming this week on the
content because it's just going to be
ridiculous
but apart from that absolute top secret
so today
what we're going to be talking about is
one of the questions that
i people not ask me but they tell me one
of these people say to me a lot is they
say
samuel after seeing your videos loads
um it's really weird because you're
actually nicer in real life
than you are on your videos that's what
people often tell me interesting it is
interesting isn't it
they're often shocked as if they think
they think i'm gonna be
a jerk i think it's because you're so
hard aren't you and so direct so i think
when people see you they just think
i don't know that you're in that mode
all the time but yeah
so often people say that they were
pleasantly surprised when meeting me for
the first time
so on this video i wanted to talk about
some of the people that we've met and
talk about what our
experience maybe famous people um what
our experience has been meeting them
have they been like what we
think they would be like nicer or less
nice so
i'm gonna go first with choice of
celebrity
and then maybe i'll give you someone you
give me someone okay and and then we'll
see how we go so
what was it like meeting
in person i'm gonna start with a really
hard one
oh really hard one because you won't
want to talk about this
i don't think um i'm gonna start with
robert
kiyosaki oh robert kiyosaki okay
it was interesting interesting i think i
was quite
a bit underwhelmed i think it was like a
dinner setting that
you know it was a really close intimate
thing and you're actually interviewing
him
yeah so i don't know i kind of thought
he'd have a bit more
life in him i thought he'd be a bit more
energetic and just i don't know really
friendly
yeah i thought he'd be really friendly
because he's an older person and i just
always think
older people usually are quite friendly
i remember like a nice little granddad
type you know
i've been brought up kiyosaki a few
times and i remember saying to you
i don't think he's going to be an easy
interviewer and you were like
well yeah i thought it'd be such a cozy
and he's very blunt um i think his way
depends what day you catch him because
i've seen him a few times sometimes he's
being friendly and nice
other times he's not being quite so
not he's not a nice guy right he's not
would you i mean
he's not i mean he just seemed a bit
rude and a bit off
but maybe it was just about he's a
walking legend
yeah and he's got a lot of wisdom and i
have a lot of respect for him
but yes be warned if you meet robert
kiyosaki in person
do not expect a friendly nice
conversation you won't get a cuddle
no no you won't he will ignore you or he
will be rude to you
or whatever and also he'll never
remember you no matter how many times
you know how many times you meet him
he'll never remember who you are
um but i guess sometimes in business to
get to that point you kind of have to be
a bit
like that maybe people expect me to be
like in person what robert is like he's
actually
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's like total
businessman just
you know okay i have one for you okay
arnold schwarzenegger
what was he like my goodness arnold
schwarzenegger
i didn't meet him in a super intimate
setting i met him um
it was like i think you were there
actually when i was there yeah it was um
so so there was a dinner and a big q and
a
speech but then i did meet him backstage
very briefly
had a photo with him uh however
he from what i saw the small amount that
i saw of arnold schwarzenegger
was absolutely awesome really nice
humble
guy a real presence about him as well
you know i think that's the thing as
well like sometimes you meet people that
you see on
on tv or on youtube or on stage or you
know you've looked up to them for years
and then when you meet them in real life
they've got no presence about them
they've got no aura they're just like
ooh
couldn't be or where where whereas
honest wilson had a real
presence about him and humility about
him
and a kindness about him so yeah
mad respect i wish i wish i'd have had
longer to actually talk to him because
it was
you know it was all a bit busy but yeah
he seemed nice
nice great guy yeah not just nice
powerful inspirational kind
humble nothing but amazing things to say
about arnold schwarzenegger and i really
respect where he came from
yeah i loved his story when he told his
story it was just really
really happy okay my one for you is
the embarrassing story oh i know where
this is going
i know the embarrassing story of the
time that
we met your hero
mr kevin hart kevin hart if you're
watching this kevin
i love you so much he's so good
but yeah kevin hart he was just so
friendly and so
nice i think everything that i thought
he would be yeah was that
he was everything you thought he would
yeah but you were everything you
thought you wouldn't i know i was so
nervous when i met him i just can't
believe
here's the funny thing basically mandy
always said to me she goes do you know
what samuel
if kevin knew me me and kevin knew each
other
we would be mates we've got the same
humor
true we're like the same person me and
kevin would be
bessies and i was like okay so uh he was
doing a big tour
and i arranged to meet kevin
in the vip backstage area after the show
uh i think
i can't remember exactly how it worked i
think you had to pay like i don't know a
few thousand yeah front row literally
yeah and then you and then you could
just meet with them afterwards limited
to like five or six people
um and we did and we went and we and i
was like hey
we're going to kevin's show you were
really excited about that and now i told
you that you could actually be
meeting him you get to have a proper
conversation photos chat with him
and you like oh yeah yeah yeah but then
actually oh my gosh i couldn't believe i
couldn't even get my words out you were
quite underwhelming
i know i didn't want to be disappointed
probably doesn't remember me now because
i wasn't memorable at all oh
you were you were but yeah really good
experience
really he was very nice we definitely go
see him again live
and and she was showing him pictures of
our children he was pretending to be
interested
i think you i think he genuinely was and
if he wasn't he
it still came across as if he was if he
was interested then he's the strangest
man ever
to be interested in pictures of some
random person's kids just yeah
really really good so yeah okay one for
you then yeah
someone who i actually admire a lot and
i haven't had the
the what's the word i'm looking forward
to the opportunity to meet them yes
grant cardone have you ever no i haven't
what happened you must have made it no
you've met him loads but i've never been
there
have you ever even seen him live
speaking no no no no no
just read his books but never actually
met him okay grand caller down so tell
me what he's like
yes let's talk about grant cardone yeah
he's the opposite
of robert kiyosaki in terms of robert
kiyosaki's a bit harsh on camera and a
bit gruff and stuff and then you meet
him and he's even worse
oh right gran cardone is kind of like in
your face a little bit aggressive and
stuff like that
but actually in real life he's one of
the sweetest
nicest kindest people you'll ever meet
really really really cares about other
people
very calming you know yes he's got
really good energy and he's a bit hyper
and stuff like that probably a little
bit like me
yeah but he is just i remember the first
time i met grant was when i was
interviewing him on my youtube channel
uh-huh and i just interviewed robert
kiyosaki and because i just interviewed
robert kiyosaki and robert kiseki was a
jerk okay
i'm just gonna say as it is he was a
jerk he was the hardest person to
interview ever
okay um but then i was thinking like oh
and and i kind of wasn't looking forward
to interviewing grant i've never met him
before i just thought
is this gonna be another frigging
gruelling interview where i mean
it's gonna be like getting blood out of
a stone but actually
i sat down with grant and it was the
absolute night and day it was absolutely
opposite he was
very very sweet very easy to talk to
after the interview finished he was he
was chatting with me
when the cameras turned off was really
complimentary about me
and my business and youtube channel was
just really nice didn't charge a penny
did it
just purely um because he did what he
wanted to
and after that we became friends and he
became my mentor i paid him a bunch of
money
and um no i really like him very very
very nice guy really cares
direct to the point but sweet and with a
good heart so nothing but good things to
say about
grand cardo no which takes me to my next
mentor
[Laughter]
who i never actually said with my mentor
ever
i said i said i had a mentoring session
with him which i did
but um mr
mr allen lord allen sugar sugar
oh what do you think what do you make of
what do you make of that [ __ ] to be
honest
i think he's literally just a grumpy old
man i mean literally the other day i
showed you a tweet that he tweeted about
someone it was about martin lewis
just a really nasty tweet out of nowhere
totally unprovoked and i just thought
who's happy in their life didn't you say
like does this didn't he tweet just the
other day where he was like oh
oh it hasn't martin lewis i really want
to punch his face
i said i just got a face that i want to
punch i was like who said just literally
just
that was what was his whole tweet yeah
just i want to punch his face
i was just like wow but yeah he just
comes across as a bit grumpy i can't
imagine him as being quite friendly and
stuff but
you obviously met him yeah what did you
think of him when you met him
i actually i actually liked him did you
yeah i actually liked him when i met him
um he was very similar to like what he's
like on camera
he was you know grilled grab my business
plan but then i actually become really
west what surprised me so much when he
started
um you know being a jerk afterwards but
we actually got on quite well
yeah and i shared my business plan
everybody else he was really horrible
too but actually to me he was quite nice
to me like my business
you know he really helped me change
things so
lord sugar is a grumpy old man but
i do think i do respect him he's
achieved a lot yeah
and you know not like i tell you who is
who is somebody that i do not respect at
all who's been in the newspapers
recently as well so this is a bit
relevant
and that is um joe licen the comedian oh
he's just he's just at all isn't he's
an idiot yeah what's he been
he was in the papers for he was
basically he said that he shouldn't have
i can't remember who's anyone is but
certain plastic type bottles
okay and then he got called out on live
tv and they showed a picture of him
where he had the bottle
and then he walked out he took his mic
off and walked out
and it was really awkward he looked
really stupid but then he then came out
saying oh it was all staged it was all
planned i was doing it just for
attention how convenient
if you were if you weren't you're a tall
man and then and then he said about me
he was like oh i
am i spent three months trying to meet
samuel
and all this he never messaged me once
yeah and then he was all
nervous and then came he was just a tour
everyone hated him at my show
he came down to the crash course
everybody hated him he was getting booed
and stuff
um he is just the most unfunny comedian
and he's just really um
i just now talking of punchable face
lord sugar you can punch his face
[Laughter]
i don't want to just bash everybody okay
um okay you've met
gary vaynerchuk haven't you of course
and tell
tell us then about the experience
because again i've never met i've never
actually seen him like gary vaynerchuk i
met gary vaynerchuk
we had a oh it was called like a 4d
where a 4d
i think it was like where you pay like
10 grand and you sit around a table with
gary vaynerchuk and spend a day
looking at your business plan and you
know it was cool
um gary vaynerchuk is very similar like
you probably expect him to be
he's really high energy he doesn't
listen to what you say and he cuts you
in constantly
it was so difficult just asking me
questions because i go right my question
gary is but and i'd start to ask the
question and then as i'd
be like 20 seconds into my question he
would then just cut me and he'd have
some idea
why do i feel like i feel like he's the
kind of person that always has to be the
loudest in the room
i don't think he i don't think it's an
ego thing i think it's because he's got
so much to say right
a lot of good stuff and his mind is
running a million miles an hour and
you'll start to say something and then
he'll oh that reminds me of
oh actually talking of that and he just
constantly cuts you and stuff
but actually i think he's got a really
good heart and i think he's extremely
intelligent okay very very good at
business and entrepreneurship and i
loved it and he really supported me on
my very first financial freedom
challenge
because when i met him i was about to do
it and he was like rooting for me
generous with his time happy to he was
very very nice like gary vaynerchuk got
a lot of respect from don't know him
super well
only had the opportunity to meet him um
once but it was a proper meet up
and i can only really say good things
about gary vaynerchuk
nice cool okay just um as we wrap it up
who would you because these people that
you've mentioned you obviously met them
all in a
business type setting yeah who would you
like i met kevin hart because i just
love kevin hart as a comedian
who would you pay to meet who's not like
in the business world
like who's who interests you like who
would you love to meet eminem
okay would that be fun i can imagine
that could be underwhelming i'm not
really sure
okay i don't know actually meeting
eminem i mean look i grew up an mnm fan
so i
oh yeah i would love it i would be very
excited to be eminem
but i actually think i'd have a better
afternoon with will smith yeah you love
will smith
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think but there's
a lot of people man
there's a lot of people so we'll take
some questions from the fans
cool from the audience let's see what we
thank god and if you have any questions
that you have burning then you should
comment them down
right now and if also if there's anybody
that you think we should get on this
youtube channel
uh if you'd like to see maybe amanda
interviewing kevin hart or something
like that
then we'll see if we can make it happen
all right so
emmanuel says great watching you guys
again this weekend
samuel i've got a question for you how
did you get your wife to start to work
for slash with you did you ask her
already
what she wanted uh how organic man
um with amanda she didn't need to come
and work on the business
she was working as a quantity surveyor
we got married
she quit because she wanted to go on
holidays and stuff and she didn't want
to be tied down to a job anymore
and then you just naturally just started
helping working on the business
yeah as it happens i've got an interest
in property anyway so but then amanda's
help became
like the business then suddenly the
business suddenly like stopped
having had steroids yeah and blew up
because amanda's a smart
smart lady and then it says have you
always wanted to work in the property
sector
oh this is a question for you okay or
have
you got other dreams outside of property
oh okay
um so i enjoy working in the property
sector but a random dream of mine which
i'm sure i'll have at some point is to
have my own clothing boutique
i just love the idea of it and it's just
something that i think sounds like a bit
of fun i might do that as a hobby as
i get older another dream that you've
had as well is
you keep talking about you want to have
a nail shop right yeah
yeah like a yeah like a nail spy you
just come chatting with
girls having your nails done having a
glass of champagne that sort of thing i
just
yeah basically somewhere i love i just
love the idea of people just coming in
having happy customers all the time and
just being able to serve people and make
them feel relaxed
okay next question what is the
definition of a multi-millionaire
quite a few people in london etc are
classed as millionaires by virtue of
owning a house this is
james green by the way are you a
multi-millionaire if you say own 10
million pounds in property but have nine
million pounds
mortgaged come on monday what's a
multi-millionaire
a multi-millionaire so if you take
someone's
assets everything that they earn minus
all their debts
and then what they're left with their
net worth if that's a million then
they're a millionaire if there's
multiple like if it's like a lot more
than a million
then they're a multi-millionaire so how
many would it take which would be a more
i would probably say multi i mean i've
heard
i guess technically i guess telling you
three right yeah i think three i think
a couple's two and then multi would be
three or more yeah if you're if you're
uh
if you've got three million pounds net
profit in your in your portfolio or
business or whatever
then that's multiple so i would probably
say you're a multi-millionaire
um so if you've got 10 million but 9
million mortgaged
you are not a multi-millionaire you are
in fact a millionaire
[Music]
last question quite a few people said
they wanted to hear about the charity
stuff in terms of
me saying that charity certain charities
um
actually or certain charitable works
actually hinder people as opposed to
help
um i don't really think we've got time
to talk about that this week i'm really
sorry
i'm gonna i think we should probably
maybe talk about that next week because
there's a lot of examples that i've got
where um
that that is the case and i could end up
talking for another 20 minutes
um but anyway i hope you've enjoyed this
podcast
of samuel and amanda's show talking
about money marriage live who we've met
and what we think of those people any
questions at all comment below because
we will answer your questions in next
week's video
and to wrap up amanda what are your
final words of
wisdom okay final words of wisdom
supporting another success won't dampen
yours
an example that i can think of that is
actually just been being at the crash
course and seeing you samuel
you are teaching people training people
and sharing you know your success
sharing what you've learned i feel like
some people when they become successful
they don't want to share
because they feel like i don't want
anyone else to be like me but i feel
like
you doing that doesn't take anything
away from you so
i think like you know should cheer other
people on and not try to pull people
down
and you know there's only good that can
come from it absolutely
pulling or pushing other people up is
actually gonna gonna help you go higher
as well
people that try and tear down other
people to make themselves
look or feel better it's actually
completely illogical and does not work
so keep inspiring other people keep
spreading the love and the positivity
and we will see you next time don't
forget to subscribe
like the video and thanks so much for
watching thank you bye